stream for those of you all who have not
been here before this is a way for us
all to stay connected as you have now
school closures around the world khan
academy we're not for profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and the
way we've been doing that for years is
by making resources from as early as
pre-k khan academy kids that goes
through kindergarten and first grade
and then resources in math english
language arts
science humanities all the way through
elementary middle high school and even
the foundations of college that's always
been there but when the school closures
started happening a few weeks ago we
realized oh it's our duty to do more so
we've been doing parent webinars and
teacher webinars this daily live stream
to stay connected
and uh we've been publishing things like
schedules for students of different age
groups and over the course of the next
few hours actually we're going to be
publishing some learning plans for
students in different at different grade
levels for how you can learn through the
end of the school year and keep learning
ideally through the summer i do want to
remind folks we are a not-for-profit and
we're funded with by philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to khan academy i
do want to give a quick shout out to
several corporations who stepped up in
the last few weeks when they saw that
our
folks like bank of america att
google.org and novartis uh and i want to
thank our many other supporters uh but
even with that we were running at a
deficit before conocat before the crisis
hit and uh the the the costs have gone
even higher but with that i'd like to
introduce our guest for today uh david
coleman
uh from the college board ceo of the
college board another not-for-profit
that we have been close partners with
for many years around official sat
practice and david may be a good place
to start even before our live stream
started and i encourage everyone to ask
questions on the message boards we have
team members looking at it but we had a
lot of questions about
ap exams and how that's all going to
work out so i'd love to hear how you all
are thinking about it and how it's going
to play out for students
thanks sal and i hope you and your
family as well and your colleagues are
well during this demanding time
i know people are working at home and
facing the demands of sometimes their
children and other forces and
not to be somber but i know this can be
has already been for some and will be
for others a time of loss
and uh i just want to offer our
heartfelt condolences and
and support for people who are
struggling through this
and um i know it sounds weird to begin
this way but there are definitely things
more important this life than ap and sat
uh and those include the safety and
sanctity of everyone and uh i know you
and i are also very concerned that this
crisis will hit the low income
and underrepresented communities hardest
in this country is it things like this
always do and that's why khan academy is
such a beacon uh available on any device
to any person
what an equalizer
and i'll talk a little bit why the
digital divide can can still make that
hard but i don't know of a force
that is as astonishing as khan academy
is
in offering such a high quality to
everyone when we partnered with khan
academy it was not to provide free test
prep sal as you said it was provide the
best test prep that happened to be free
and khan academy has delivered on that
uh the quality of your team's work and
everything it touches continues to amaze
me and inspire me and us at the college
board
and um i i just my most important
message today may be
never has the importance of khan academy
been more re evident to the world
and i just hope people listening to this
uh really understand that donating to
one of the great public utilities of our
time one of the great public goods of
our time which is khan academy is urgent
and important it is it's now evident
that it is essential to everyone alive
and let's help make it so by investing
in it so um you know that we invest in
you due to your great work in in in the
svt with us
and you've you've uh you know we work
with a lot of players in this space we
regard none higher than khan academy in
the quality of its work and its ethos so
sorry for that long preamble but um i
think that's really important um
and actually well
and how are you doing i mean it's my bad
yeah you're in new york
i'm i'm really involved
my husband is an icu nurse so i'm super
proud of him he's on the front lines
every day and i'm trying to do my best
to keep them safe and help them along
and we have young twins that are five
that are irreverent as ever
and uh they're thriving i i cannot
complain of my individual circumstances
and i could talk about as many people
have my concerns about my parents in
various places and
all of that but all together sal were
well and we at the college board are
energized uh by what we're attempting to
do we've chosen to
come at this crisis with a spirit of
innovation and flexibility and so let me
outline
what we're doing about ap because i know
people have a lot of questions i'm going
to apologize i'll read a couple of
things here because i want to get the
facts exactly right and then turn to
your questions
i hope i've made clear that the health
and safety of educators
families is the most important thing
driving the college board and of course
students at this time that is our top
priority
so as students and families and teachers
navigate these challenges we've done two
pivotal things
first we have launched ap live to
provide every student in a regular
schedule each day free online review and
coursework around every ap course and as
of now there have been 4.7 million views
of that content
and number two
we're providing all students the chance
to test safely at home this spring and
i'll outline that assessment opportunity
and to be clear before we made that
decision which was a hard decision
because it forces an enormous amount of
work and innovation on the college for
its part to design an at-home exam but
but we found when we surveyed ten
thousand the excuse me eighteen thousand
students that over ninety one percent of
them said they wanted the opportunity to
take an exam and claim the credit we've
earned let's remember the crisis hit
after seventy five percent of the school
year was done so these are students
who've been working all year in their ap
classrooms so we felt that we could make
only one principal decision
that we would provide a brief at-home
exam to allow students to show what
they've learned and that exam could only
cover
information in that first 75 percent of
the course units that are typically
covered so we will not include the
material that is typically covered in
march and april when schools were out of
session
if you want to learn more about either
ap live or the exams you can always go
to cb.org slash ap
let me tell you a little bit more about
the solution it will be a 45-minute
online exam at home for this year and
this year alone
educator-led development communities
which are a blend of higher education
professors and high-end high school
teachers ap teachers are currently
selecting the exam questions that will
be administered
exams will be given may 11th through
15th and may 18th to 22nd
and make up test dates will be available
for each subject from june 1st to 5th
but i strongly encourage all students to
take the exam in that original testing
window when we're more assured of our
full capacity to reach every student
and as i mentioned before
we recognize that the digital divide
could prevent some low income and rural
students from participating
working with partners we're heavily
investing so these students have the
tools and connectivity and technical
support they need to review ap content
online and take the exam
if if you're a student who needs help or
or you're a teacher whose students need
mobile tools or connectivity you can
reach out to us directly to let us know
by april 24th please complete the form
at cb.org
tech cb.org tech and i'm really proud
that 50 of my colleagues have given of
their time to reach out directly to
these families and students to make sure
that we complete the last mile and
understand the pressures on homeless
students and other students in our
society that may be without devices or
bandwidth or in homes where bandwidth is
scarce and devices are shared
we'll continue to support students with
free resources through exam day
and while we encourage students to wait
until closer to the test date to decide
any student now registered for exam can
choose to cancel at no charge
and i have good news we're confident
that the vast majority of higher
education institutions will honor the
credit from these courses we've gotten
an overwhelming response the university
of california just published a statement
i believe it's now to 22 states that
have endorsed this solution and several
private institutions and more coming in
every day so there's enormous consensus
in higher ed to honor the work done on
these exams and give credit and
placement accordingly so for seniors it
will offer credit and placement for
their futures if they succeed and for
juniors who will offer all of that and
also distinguish themselves on the way
to college and at a time when families
incomes are compromised across this
country we felt it was our obligation
sal the press on innovation in order to
make sure kids didn't lose their chance
to earn the credit that they had done i
could say a little bit more later if
you'd like about the ap live sessions
and i've told you you can go to the
website and look at it i just want to be
clear though that nothing that happens
in ap live as cool as i think it is will
be required on the exam we know some
kids will not have access to future
online learning so the exams only cover
what you've already done in the first 75
percent of the course
we'll be adding
optional student practice online for
students to practice for free
and again let me say a little bit more
now about the exams
there for this year only we'll go back
to our traditional ap exams
these streamlined exams will not require
any test book shipments external
proctors or any additional workload
again
the exam content will only cover topics
and skills most ap teachers and students
have already covered in class by march
and students will be able to take these
streamlined exams on any device they
have access to a computer a tablet or a
smartphone they can even take a picture
on a smartphone of their handwritten
work and upload that
most exams will be given from may 11th
to the 22nd and take up and and
as i said the makeup dates will be in
june 1st to 5th in the unlikely event
that schools reopen students can take
these exams there
let me say a little bit more about the
exam format
most exams will have one or two free
response questions and each question
will be timed separately so students
will need to write and submit their
responses within the allotted time for
each question
for most subjects the exams will be 45
minutes long plus an additional five
minutes for uploading
students will need to access the online
testing system 30 minutes early to get
set up
certain courses such as apr and design
2d art and design 3d computer science
principles drawing research and seminar
will use portfolio submission and will
have a set it will not have a separate
online exam
all deadlines for these submissions have
been extended to may 26th
at 11 59 p.m for those who cut it close
eastern time
teachers and students will receive
special course specific communications
on these on these projects
and interestingly excitingly students
taking world language and culture exams
will complete solely two spoken tasks
consistent with free response questions
three and four in the current ap exam
they'll be giving an oral exam by a
qualified adult and so we're really
going direct from readers to students to
hear their command of the language
as you can see what we've tried to do is
we've tried to make the exams much
simpler
briefer i want students to feel
confident that they've got this you've
done the work the first three quarters
of the exam we're not trying to trick
you we're not trying to surprise you
we're actually trying to just give you a
venue to show you what you know i've
never been more confident the majority
of students should be able to flourish
on these exams
and if you want sell i'll end with a few
words on security because i must because
of course people wonder how can we give
these exams securely at home
like many college level exams they'll be
open book and open note the exam format
and questions are being designed
specifically for an at-home
administration so points won't be given
to you for things you could find out
from google or elsewhere online
however
now i must be more than clear
students may not consult with any other
individuals during the testing period
and we'll take the necessary steps to
protect the integrity of the exam
administration
and you know i say this i'm confident
that the vast majority of ap students
will follow the rules for taking the
exams and there's something kind of
crazy about cheating on an ap exam
because who wants to wind up in advanced
calculus that's not ready for it
but we will nonetheless put in strict
measures to avoid cheating including
pagerism software and several other
efforts i don't want to go into them in
too much depth because the more i talk
about them they're not as strong as
security measures
but they are strong and they surround
the student in various ways and they
they are taking seriously the
possibility of students having someone
else impersonate themselves and show
their work or
going to the internet to share with
other students or conference calls with
their students we've thought of all the
scenarios and put tactics in place
but i need to warn students in this
special circumstance the college board
will be tougher on cheating students who
are found cheating in this kind of
situation we will not only as usual
merely cancel your score we're going to
get let every university know that
you've sent an sat score if we have
conclusive evidence that you've sent an
sat score or other ap scores to that you
were found cheating this environment so
it would be a foolish move that would
limit one's future to cheat in this
environment
but that said
putting that dark specter aside i think
this is an extraordinary opportunity for
ap students there's free live lessons
every day brief exams that will
reinforce that will reflect your mastery
and i really look forward to see what
kids can do and students can
yeah that's that's super helpful and i
think it already addresses a lot of the
questions that we've been getting and a
few things you mentioned that i think
are interesting and uh address some
questions that i think we can highlight
from instagram
earthly 1008 asked i have only a mobile
phone and i took ap calc bc so it'll be
possible for me to take the exam it
sounds like it will
it will it will the only disadvantage of
a mobile phone is typically in the
humanities when some of the prompts may
be a little longer it'll be a little
annoying to scroll through them on your
phone but that doesn't mean that you can
either then type back your answers on
the mobile phone or in the bc calculus
situation that person could write their
work take a picture of it and upload it
with them
but then they can get all the prompts
from the phone they can get the
questions from the phone yep and what
about students who don't even have that
or they're maybe afraid that their their
phone isn't good enough you mentioned
cb.org tech how would that work that's
exactly right the way it's working so
it's really exciting we we and that when
we made the announcement we we gave that
address to every student and 2 000 of us
have got in touch with us and we're
getting back to them we have thousands
of chromebooks and we're trying to make
sure those chromebooks get to just those
students who need them most who really
can't borrow a device or need them on
test day so we're trying to really ask
people to be restrained in what they ask
for we're going to loan them out and ask
for them back we're working with other
state and district partners to ensure
that that their device strategies are
coordinated and they're getting to these
ap students who need them a lot of this
sell as you know is case management and
we're investing today in providing wide
reaching tech support because sometimes
it's actually tech support that gets in
the way but if you have a concern please
go to cv.org
that's super helpful i have a question
from youtube dara ray blot is asking
will there be practice tests example
questions in the same style as the new
at-home questions
yes there will and some of them are
going to roll out by the end of the week
and then we will be having more practice
for you we may even have uh we're just
designing now ways that you can simulate
the test experience and test the systems
and where you can further take practice
questions as you go so the answer is yes
already by the end of the week there'll
be practice and there'll be more to come
as we further develop
and there's two questions here they're
related one is from on they're both from
youtube aisha condom is asking will the
ap exam be harder to compensate for open
notes and lucy is asking how is the ap
curve going to work for students if the
tests are going to be open notes
well the curve is not really affected
because you're still evaluating students
on a one through five scale as to
whether their work represents
college-ready work at a more or less
advanced level and we're still going to
have the distributed reading process so
readers won't meet in person but will
still have college faculty and and ap
teachers reading the work and making
those judgments
i think students should enter this exam
situation with great confidence i want
to be clear that if you look at what's
happening in higher ed and what's
happening in the ap program we're trying
to get every chance to students days we
know that students are under very
stressful circumstances and so we're
trying to make the exam as brief as
possible we don't want to surprise
anyone we want to make the questions as
much as possible look like work already
done in the class
so that we can look at that value-added
analysis you can do the synthesis you
can do the analysis you do not just
regurgitate facts but we're not trying
to trick you in any way and it should be
very routine with the kind of work
you've already been doing in the
classroom
and there's another question here around
technology from facebook alpana loyalca
asks
we have internet issues from time to
time what would be a good backup that
you would suggest in case that happens
in the middle of the exam
i think then the makeup testing is going
to be essential so so what i would like
people to do is what we're not finding
so far in our testing i know people
worry about like the earth-shattering
moment the internet goes down just at
the very moment they're testing but
what's more likely is people haven't
checked their browsers and haven't gone
through the exam
stimulation process and have a tech
support issue they didn't expect so we
will ask students to go through
simulations in advance and i'm kind of
as much as possible asking all students
to really do that and we will monitor
that closely and and second of all as i
said please sign up 30 minutes before
the exam begins
that's that's useful and there's a lot
of questions uh for those of y'all who
don't know the college board which y'all
are not for profit that represents
essentially a board of colleges you
represent what the colleges are thinking
on a lot of levels uh and y'all are also
as we talked about earlier the
administrator of the sat and we're close
partners on that around official sat
practice a couple of questions on that
front but related to this notion of
at-home potential at-home testing from
youtube tom burt is asking is the
college board preparing for home online
sat testing and the eventuality cova 19
prevents using testing centers in june
uh i think the eventuality in which the
college board is preparing for and that
i've talked about in a previous
communication so our members sell just
to be clear are virtually all the
nation's high schools and all the
colleges and so we work together with
high schools and colleges to make that
connection not only domestically but
globally and the sat is part of that but
my brief answer to the question is i
think we will need an at-home style
solution for the sat if schools are out
this fall and we'll be giving more
updates on our progress towards that in
about a week's time but we have
announced that we are preparing in that
sad eventuality that our society really
is off kilter and kids can't get back
into a school setting by this fall
that we will develop alternatives
yeah and there's one thing that i think
you said two questions ago that i really
want to highlight some when people are
asking about the curve of ap it's really
important for people to recognize if if
everyone who takes the ap exam knows the
material at a five level you will give
everyone a five if no one does all right
let's talk at once
once again showing that you are better
at this than i am sometimes no kidding
kidding aside it's a perfect thing sal
says there is no curve in that sense
it's not like there are only 75s to give
out so many fours so many threes
we
we are really trying to create a
situation where students who have done
the work of this class came with
confidence to do well in this exam
i just want to be clear about something
oh sorry sal we know that like while
it's cool that we have ap live that a
lot of a lot of students have other
things going on right now and they might
just have the time to take the exam and
we've really designed this exam to make
sure that even if you don't have a bunch
of time to do a lot of studying in
between now and then you still should be
able to show your work and do well so
we've tried to be very attentive to the
mix of circumstances our students find
themselves in
and we've gotten a ton of questions not
just today but in previous live streams
around i think it's mainly high school
juniors who are just stressed a little
bit about the college application
process generally given all of their
volatility they might not have i know
some of the local districts have gone
past fail uh for this term
you all represent these colleges yeah in
all things admissions and things like
that what are you hearing from them
yeah let me i'm going to do my best to
give you as straight as shot as i can
sell i would urge
immense calm on the part of students for
a certain reason colleges want them more
than ever
colleges are concerned about filling
their classes about students coming back
so don't think it hasn't affected
everyone so colleges are hungrier than
ever for talent are hungrier to other
defined students they're worried
about recruiting students they're
worried about students from various
communities not being adequately
represented on their college campuses so
it's never been a better time to be a
student applying to college there's such
a hunger among the nation's colleges to
re-engage with you get back in touch
with you and develop your plans with you
don't don't sweat the small stuff a pass
fail grade or taking the sat later in
the year than you expected you know
claim your opportunity with ap get it
done but but but this is a time where
everyone realizes what's important and
and all i would tell you is if there is
a blessing at a time like this from what
i know about college admissions
is
high school students many of them could
do with being a lot less busy sell
sometimes applying to college has become
this frenzy of doing tons of activities
and trying to distinguish yourself every
which way and the truth of college
admissions is is doing very well your
schoolwork and doing one thing outside
of it that you love and show your
strength in is really enough and i hope
that that as we realize as this crisis
makes clear that real love for a few
things matters more than being busy and
time with family and i hope that we come
back to a more balanced approach as we
return to schooling this fall
and that's a good segue david you know i
want to give you a chance i know and i
applaud what you and the entire college
board team is doing i i can't imagine
all of the complexities you're trying to
navigate right now
time
but you know i always for those of y'all
who don't realize david and i are
actually quite good friends uh over the
course of many years we've had many late
night conversations where i'm uh you
know trying to expand david's
imagination in one direction or another
and he's doing this
for the record
maybe we'll get in we'll get into it but
what i always tell people even when we
first partnered with the college board
and feel like oh the college board
that's that big institution that
administers these tests and all this i
was like you've got to meet david he's
not what you're imagining as as the ceo
the president of the college board and
frankly everyone at the college board
are these really thoughtful people who
are really out there to just do right by
you the students and the teachers and
the parents and so david i i want to
give and i've always admired you for
your ability to think broadly about life
and where we sit and and and and history
and things like that you know what
advice do you have for for everyone
going through this as people and but
especially as students right now
many people will say to you that
everything has changed
and so i want to start by what remains
the same
the most powerful thing you can do as a
student
is to develop authentic fascinations
and what i hope ap is for students is a
chance
to gain the pleasure and challenge of
getting really good at something
and i know that sounds super simple but
i want you to
to to think for a moment about this one
precious life you've been given and how
meaningful it is to get fascinated by
something to to fall into something
and uh when you think about applying to
college if you think boy what does it
really take it takes getting to know
your teachers really well and finding
some great teachers because those
mentors are everything to us
it means falling in love with
your academic work to some degree but
particularly certain parts of it and
then it's finding an activity outside of
school that you devote yourself to
and what's funny sal is before the
crisis we have research on success at
college that says if you do those things
when you get to college you're gonna
have a great experience if you find
great teachers if you if you find a
class or discipline that you love and
apply to your life
and if you love an activity outside of
class
so i know that sounds strange but it
seems to me
that success remains as simple as kind
of falling in love three times you know
uh being devoted to your to your
teachers and and the relationships you
have with them to to disciplines and
finding academic work that really makes
you awake at night and excites you and
finally
finding an activity that engages you and
when sal and i look at each other
and care for one another
it's in part because we both love what
we do
sal is a man energized entirely by
passion he began khan academy
sharing his delight in math with his
nephew and nieces it began
as an act of love as the kind of
irrepressible desire to bring other
people into the beauty and power that he
found in mathematics
sal's passion for that changed the world
and
that cultivation of passion and
excellence is such a winning hand it
faking it being inauthentic putting a
face on yourself for college
applications getting caught up in doing
too many things is waste the precious
life we've been given but but working
hard to discover what you love finding
teachers that really move you these are
lasting things and and what you'll find
is later in life
you know sal says he's impressed with
the responsiveness of the college board
and honestly i kind of am too a lot of
people have really canceled exams and we
came to this with a very innovative can
do we're going to make it work at home
attitude but that's in part because
we've been working for with khan academy
for years and we've seen their agility
and they inspire us and so i think that
uh
i think that we may be more distant from
one another for a period of time
but what really matters remains
strangely the same
and never has your own motivation your
own inner drive been more important than
now
out of the presence of your teachers out
of the immediate pressures of applying
to college can you cultivate that
internal flame
that really is what delivers you most
things of value in this life
so that's my uh pompous preaching for
the day so i'm done
i think i think that's going to leave a
lot of students and and and some of us
adults
inspired and i think it's exactly right
it's uh you know i think the first few
weeks of this social distancing all of
us were fixated on the thing that we
were losing uh but now i think
and i know some people are in very hard
situations and everyone is going through
a lot of anxiety and stress but we're
starting to realize that there's some
silver linings more time with family
a lot of the noise of everyday life has
gone away and we have we can reflect
more more time with ourselves to think
about what makes us tick who are we
really and i think for high school
students especially
the the normal world is
there's just so much going on in their
life they don't have the time to reflect
and and this generation all of y'all out
there uh actually
there might be a silver lining where you
have an opportunity to do what david
mentioned you have the time to reflect
who you are what really energizes you
and be your authentic self as you
applied for college uh so uh thanks
david for for joining us i hope we can
have him on again we got a lot of
questions today more more so than normal
so i know there's a lot of high school
students out there thinking a lot about
college admissions and aps and sats and
uh you know i always applaud david for
uh you know his ability to really speak
to the heart as you just saw
thanks everyone for joining as i said
this is a way for all of us to stay
connected not just for you all to stay
connected but i also get a lot of
personal joy and i'm also socially
distanced to be able to connect with all
of y'all and as a reminder we are not
for profit if you're in a position to do
so please think about donating to khan
academy so that we can continue to
support the world hopefully in this time
of crisis and and beyond
have have a good day
you